okay so we'll start at the end of
katat
okay and
um it's
components okay that go
into the
khole so I don't consider this a
pin okay because he can roll out he can
because basically it's a
Kimura from your nibble
wait just you're in the wrong place just
chill is this a Cura without anything
protecting against the turn do you all
understand that so just to make sure
here we go we're going to do the
Cur I just basic Kimura come around and
I don't put my leg on him I go for it
and he'll roll out of it
okay
so there is nothing protecting the turn
you see in
K he's going to roll out of it there's
nothing stopping that there's not a pit
okay if you want to stop that you have
to come
into the same kind of position and you
have to depost the other arm so here is
the chimur here is depost the other arm
arm and the depost arm he tries to turn
he's lends you can go ahead and try this
arm's blocking him from the turn you see
and so this
is a pin
okay
or she does the katama and her knee on
the other side you see and now together
our shoulders try to roll you can't
that's a pin
okay so this is
Kul meaning this is a way to In
traditional language release relax and
the lower energy will sink to the Earth
is where I wanted to go anyways okay
your tension is stopping that so you
release and relax accident drops down
he'll feel weight
okay
K it still has a
structure this is
key this knee in front of his
elbow where this knee is is not relevant
to to either the fake pin or the cou
hole so a lot of times people think I'm
supposed to grab your his shoulder grab
his shoulder somehow and now now he
can't roll do the roll
yeah
okay that's
dumb
okay this is
where my body needs it to be and where
his body needs it to be and where the
energy needs it to be okay so you have
some Freedom with
this
me the next
component is his
elbow has to
be on the front side of my spine so the
nose is marking my spine front means
head side his elbow has to be on the
front side of my spine can't be on the
back side of my spine if it's on the
back side of my spine this is going to
going to become a bicep move that means
my bicep has to be stronger than his
extending tricep and that's not going to
happen you're not going to get it
okay third
component his
arm has to
be above
parallel got it but below straight
you
got those degrees to work with have some
sort of angle got it that's wrong and
that's wrong
okay all things go well for
me I'm going to put the knife edge of
his
hand into the fold of my
elbow here then and hold my ghee so it's
not my bicep holding it in place got
it the other elbow upper
forearm keeps his elbow from going where
I didn't want it to
go so like draw across boom then same
thing grab
youre here then push your
Center the knee is stabilizing the
shoulder mechanism on the mat got
it all
right that doesn't
change so stand
up and we'll look at your height next to
him we're starting to get lower they're
both taller than me okay
[Music]
knee elbow in
front
here boom doesn't
change stand
up
or stand next to
him we're getting
shorter lay down
knee elbow in
front same
thing move
out let's start going up stay here while
uh stand up show your height
and right
here
boom knee elbow in front cut across
boom doesn't
change uh
Sean stand up is she taller no no all
right here we
go knee El in front I don't need to be
here do I what do I only need for his
arm I don't need to be here do you see I
can be here do you get it why speak
up what do I only what is the only
requirement on the lower arm the
elbow say it it's below straight and
it's above parall yes you got it can't
do that can't do that that's the only
thing so I'm here that's where my body
grabbed look
same exact thing stand
up see he's
taller knee there elbow there Bo can't
can't get there without doing something
weird don't need that boom
here same exact thing
okay so again the old all the elements I
need the knee front knee head knee
whatever you want to call it in front of
the shoulder elbow on the front
hemisphere of my
spine
forearm at a diagonal somewhere in
between can't be straight can't be at a
90 okay use the front hand to keep the
elbow on the front side of your body and
use the elbow your elbow to get that
angle you need okay let's try that go
okay we're going to watch her
form so already you're you're holding
just the upper arm to your body uh
you're not using the fold of your left
elbow to add to the Twist and security
of that arm but go
on and as a result keep
going the hand is now coming lower
towards the back and closer to the 90 as
she's moving into the technique okay go
and let's do it again this time watch go
you're going to do it again you going
watch for her shoulder line uh go go you
see how the left shoulder is coming
forward of the right shoulder
okay
the left shoulder coming forward of the
right shoulder go ahead get it in place
means that she's twisting do you
understand
okay you will not have the torque you
need for
here go go
go go because energy can spill out
you're going to keep trying no matter
how how hard you do do I sound like I'm
trying no I don't okay so you keep
trying did you burn out already Okay so
this
way you see
that so you're down and I'll demonstrate
it just turn and get to the same
position so your body mind recognize
what we're doing is this the same
position turn your head
around and this is where the deviation
starts do you see if I can't do simple
things I'm probably not going to do the
technique the same way
okay I'm going to do your thing so I'm
much stronger than you right okay but
I'm going to do your turning thing you
got it so I'm going to make this
shoulder go in front of this shoulder do
you understand okay so so all you're
going to do is extend your energy
out keep
extending there's no way okay so I
imagine there's someone strong enough
that could get that arm to come around
and beat the leverage mechanics but it's
not me okay and I'm much stronger than
her and then martially
as long as I was taking that's where she
draws a weapon and does all kind of
things do you see so in my failure to do
it immediately and
effortlessly I add time to the technique
where that creates openings do you
understand but secondarily outp powering
leverage mechanics is not iido that's
opposite of iido okay so since she has
so much extending energy that way you
want to take advantage of it and not try
to make the hand go around the elbow but
just use the hand to help the elbow go
this way okay so he's going to come over
here and he's going to duplicate in
energy don't block the camera that's it
do you see where my knee is remember my
knee okay and extend your energy out you
won't get to straighten your arm though
right okay so this energy is going going
this way
boom okay so w in other words it's not
going this
way this whole you could forget the the
lower arm this whole thing's going this
way okay so he can move cuz I have my
knee there I put it in place and you're
going to see that I don't turn I just
move do you see this way I'm making that
thing go that way not this thing go that
way okay and that's just like the Kimura
so you're already freaking out aren't
you okay okay so you get it's going to
look how slow I'm moving actually pay
attention to how slow and how little I'm
moving yeah there you go you see you get
it you don't have to freak out like that
that's adding tension to the lock got it
but you can see oh it's in place okay
and I'm just increment increasing that
pressure you tap when you don't like it
so you can't even tell that I'm moving
I'm that close to it being on do you
understand so don't move the hand around
like a clock move the shoulder the elbow
I'm sorry the elbow forward you don't
turn your shoulders okay cuz you're not
going to be strong enough
go stand up so they can see what the
giant you are
you see okay so he's
down remember you're trying to take the
elbow you're trying to take the elbow
this elbow and you're trying to
impinge his scapula mechanism so here it
is again do you see you get it it starts
to go off though when you do that you
guys still get it but I'm deeper in the
motion you see that bring it up and you
in it early do you understand got it and
same thing you go way up and it's going
to take a while a lot more motion do you
see how much more motion okay you're
trying to impinge you're using the
shoulder impingement
okay
um because that's what I'm trying to do
with the elbow you got to watch all
these crazy things you're doing and you
have to remember it's a c hole so C hole
I said it was what what happens to your
energy
drops drops so I
go do you see that I drop it it's
dropping it's not going like this you
see that when you go up like some of you
want to do is you going
around the ball in socket you see that
or some of you like I'm going to get
him you're now going over the top of the
elbow joint got you do you see in your
effort to Crunch this elbows actually
going that way as my body curves it
creates concave space and his elbow goes
into that space so it's going that way
pay attention to his elbow it's going to
go that way do you see instead
sink this way you understand so don't
concave boom posture for CQ
projection
r he's here and he's pushing pushing
look I go like that you see no it
doesn't work oh no it doesn't work whoa
okay so here v c
projection you understand he's trying to
push me you can't tell he's trying to
push me because I'm not getting pushed
by
okay sh Rush okay got got it okay what
I'm here if I was here and I was trying
to project
that's what I'm trying to do that's what
I'm doing to him you understand so don't
go around the
elbow okay and don't create space for
the elbow to come this way don't go up
and don't crunch down okay try